we're gonna wrap it up in a little bit
here but I think we've kind of solved it
I mean I think we solved it dude body
armor fashion lines we got an arm up
yeah uh we got to have these schools
completely armed everyone armed all the
time including the kids watching each
other taking all these factors into
account yeah and then you need uh
surveillance systems too you need
surveillance at all times yeah at all
times yeah and uh yeah and that'll keep
everyone free well at least it'll give
pedophiles some jobs while they're doing
some good why not watch the kids here's
a crazy idea yeah pedophiles outside the
schools with guns the pedophiles care
about the kids nobody loves them more
the pedophiles care for the kids they
can protect the schools with guns nobody
is going to care for the world what
about an army of pedophiles around the
school with guns I love it
solved give pedophiles guns let them arm
the schools yeah and maybe uh we go back
to castles whether it's like a boat
around it's not a bad idea to just have
a like put schools in places
geographically that are harder to get to
so all the kids are in school you bring
the draw bridge up right lava and then
the honest answer is also like why have
schools when you could just send kids to
workhouses and work that's probably why
this is happening there was no shootings
when there were work houses in London
get these kids back to work cleaning
chimneys at four it's a it's a good idea
yeah I mean again folks this is you know
it's a you know it's an issue but it's
not that big of a deal it's not it's not
a big deal it's not as big of a deal as
a lot of other things yes there's a lot
of other problems that are bigger deal
what did Ricky Gervais say there's all
kinds of what did Ricky Gervais say is a
big big problem I don't think it's a bit
you know listen people are gonna die
yeah and some of them are going to be
young yeah what are you gonna do there's
nothing are you going to ban child death
it's really not as big of a deal as are
you gonna ban child death You Can't Ban
child death yeah and you know it's like
we we're all really more concerned about
what's gonna happen in this verdict with
Johnny Depp and Amber Heard oh God
what's a bigger deal what's the bigger
deal that's right what do people care
about more really yeah I think they care
more about that well it's more fun it's
more fun this is very depressing with
the kids and the the people always
getting shot it's very depressing yeah
it is fun a fake fake domination I
called it I called it months ago I said
we needed a trial
to get us out of this I said maybe Kanye
would like kill Kim and Pete or
something I said we needed a trial yeah
to get us out of the coveted malaise and
it was depth heard and I didn't even
know
uh Amber Heard breaks down on Stan I'm
getting thousands of death threats I
need a shed god
um but you know I said we needed a trial
I was correct we absolutely need a trial
we need trials on every channel we need
prank shows on every channel yeah and we
need people inside please don't leave
your house ever yeah at all just watch
this new form of entertainment it's
great because it's like it's like soccer
there's very few commercial breaks it
goes for 20 hours yeah this is the
longest trial I mean this shooting will
be out of the news in an hour yes this
won't even be relevant when it's
released on Saturday in two days this
episode won't be there'll be another
shooting by then yeah but this departing
has gone on for as long as I can
remember I think it's six weeks I feel
like I've grown up with these people I
care more about them than I do my own
family yeah and it's not even close yes
I care more about Amber Heard and Johnny
Depp than these kids that got shot
because I've been with them longer it's
just on more it's great yeah I mean it's
just it's just what it is and it's the
only thing left really that hasn't been
done right is like uh trials yeah
celebrities that are real that are drug
addicts that have beat each other up
yeah For Your Entertainment and you know
what's fun about it they're rich so
there's Butlers and maids and nannies
and assistants and like weird types of
things and there's Coachella in the
hills in Australia and we're in we're in
Italy or whatever they're doing and
they're you know it's fun to hear about
somebody getting beaten in a nice area
for once it's a good it's a good time to
be a body language expert yeah it's
really yeah they're doing real well
they're doing real well they're
providing a lot of commentary for this
yeah well I mean folks we've come up
with the solutions I don't know what you
want me to do I mean you know
unfortunately this is what happens you
can homeschool your kids and you can
shoot them yeah don't go out but it's
not just school so don't go outside well
you don't need to yeah with the
instacart and post me yeah you don't
really need no no truly now you don't
need to go you don't need to be outside
you don't need to if you go to a
national park you get abducted if you go
to the grocery store you make a shot in
the face you don't need to go outside
there's you you have streaming services
you have people that are willing to
Brave the elements to bring you nachos
and they're gonna get killed so at the
end of the day there's no real reason
you need to leave your house it's not a
big deal everything should be like going
to the airport there should be
checkpoints and metal detectors every
you shouldn't nobody should have their
shoes on ever there's one safe place in
America
there's one safe place in America and
it's Austin Texas Paradise so if you
want to live in a place where was this
shooting how far away from Austin uh so
it was 30 minutes or 90 miles west of
San Antonio so that's about three hours
I guess okay yeah yeah but now Google
Austin's shooting I bet yeah I bet
nothing comes up let's see no Austin I
bet nothing comes up Austin's just weird
at news here it's all going to be
what happened here
man shot dead by officers after he
allegedly pointed a gun at people from
his truck
that was 17 hours ago and dead after
opening fire on officers from pickup
truck in southeast Austin this is the
same thing
yeah teen arrested after shooting death
in South Austin parking lot outside LA
Fitness that was three days ago half of
Deadliest U.S shootings were in Texas oh
oh it's weird it's weird not great you
know it's weird when you go
it's not a great it's not great it's
weird when you go to like the uh the the
uh very like liberal I guess as far as
right gun laws go like you can meaning
you can have a gun you go to those
places but they have signs at all the
places where you go that say don't bring
your gun in here right you're like wait
a second I thought I was in North
Carolina what do you mean I can't bring
my gun to the Opera
why can I not have my gun at the office
you notice that all the stores have
places uh you could no guns no guns
you're like dude aren't we in North
what's the point yeah of having the gun
if I can't bring it inside well here's
the deal I mean we've been a bunch of
buffoons and goofballs but my suggestion
to everyone with children is to just
[ __ ] not get so attached
my name is Tim Dillon this special this
special that we're talking about is
called Mom love Yeah and we need a lot
less of Mom and Dad love yeah
Giannis Papas it's on YouTube right now
Mom love it's a full hour special very
very funny